and the spirit award for best screenplay
goes to
emerald fennell for a promising young
woman
thank you so much to the independent
spirit awards for this
um unbelievable honor i wish
that we could all be there in person um
to meet and celebrate this incredible
year
of film um but we can't be
so instead i'm doing my speech from my
cold
uh garrett which is slightly less
glamorous um
but it is nevertheless
every bit as exciting um to receive this
award especially
with so many other incredible nominees
in this category um there are so many
people i need to thank that i feel
this speech could go on for a thousand
years but luckily for you
i will try to keep it short um
thank you to kerry mulligan for making
me look good
and making the script uh
a thousand times better by virtue of her
genius uh thank you film nation lucky
chap
thank you focus thank you to the
incredible cast and crew
i just feel immensely lucky to have
worked with so many unbelievably
talented and kind and patient and
brilliant people
um and so this is
just more than i ever expected but i'm
very very very grateful
so thank you thank you very much
[Music]
you